Losing weight properly usually means losing it slowly,...
...by making real changes in your daily life.
Losing weight fast is possible, but it's usually not the healthiest way.
That said, there are definitely times in your life when you want to lose a few pounds fast.
And in those cases, there are ways to do it in a healthy manner.
For four days, get rid of all refined and processed carbs, sugar, artificial sweeteners,...
...and even your healthy carbs like whole grains.
This is a temporary abstention.
Whole grains are really good for you and should be a part of your regular diet.
Remove all carbonated drinks because bubbles can lead to bloat.
Cut out as much sodium as possible and no alcohol either.
What can you eat for those four days?
Stick to regular meals,...
...three meals and two snacks of lean protein like fish and eggs,...
...loads of green veggies and small portions of healthy fats...
...from nuts, avocado and olive oil.
And drink lots of water and green tea.
So remember, losing a few pounds fast isn't ideal...
...but it can be done safely if you do it right...
...and do not make this way of eating a regular habit.
You can cut a few pounds while still feeling just a little bit better.